European farm ministers meet in
Luxembourg on the twenty-fourth of June
hoping to clinch a political agreement
on major reforms of the e use vast
common agricultural policy for can the
negotiations are dragged on for around
18 months as working groups sought to
narrow down a package that will maintain
living standards for farmers and provide
secure food supplies at fair prices to
consumers it's the first time that the
reform has to be approved by all three
EU institutions the council the European
Parliament and the Commission the Irish
presidency is determined to seal a deal
by the time its term expires on jun 30
so it's invited members of parliament to
Luxembourg to discuss the outstanding
issues the cap has proved notoriously
difficult to reform and is regularly the
subject of heated debate spending on
agriculture accounts for a big slice of
the annual EU budget stover thirty
percent this year although it has been
decreasing in size the global economic
downturn has made negotiations tougher
particularly as the 27 member nations
strove to finalize the e usenext
long-term budget but farmers and
consumers alike are counting on a deal
now the reforms are focused on rules on
direct payments to farmers a common
organization of the markets in
agricultural products rural development
support and the way the cap is financed
managed monitored officials aren't
cautiously optimistic that an important
political agreement can be reached at
this council and it's possible that the
meeting will run on a 2-1 is found
should that happen the Accord would have
to be confirmed by Parliament